You're still talking to your friends?
It's complicated.
When we first got together,
we were different people.
*knocking on door*
Grampa?
Antony?
This is Martha and Bethany, this is Grampa.
Nice to meet you!
Morning!
Sorry, I barging on you.
You're not barging, he's barging!
I'm a walker.
Did you guys see Spencer?
I think we're back in.
We gotta go get him.
Are you out of your mind?!?
We haven't even picked up the dice yet!
Oh, Jesus Christ!
Do you hear something?
Spencer?
Ha?
What?
Who are you?
Oh my god!
You're Spencer's grandfather!
Are we in Florida?
And you...?
Milo Walker
Did I die?
And turned into some kind of a small muscular boy scout?
Are we dead?
Bethany?
No, no, no!
Bridge?
I'm the old fat dude!
This can't be happening!!
My hip joint feels good now!
What about this?
Look at your thighs!
Look about this!
OK.
We have some issues here.
The game is busted!
What's the game?
I'm an idiot!
Welcome to JUMANJI!
This next adventure is even more challenging.
And remember: the future of JUMANJI is in your hands!
I have one important question.
Who is JUMANJI?
Isn't that Barber's boy?
We're gonna die!
We did die.
Are we in hell?
I knew it.
Oh my god.
This is a whole new thing.
You got to have eyes in the back of your head!
What the hell?
What the hell is this?
That's your strenghts and weaknesses.
Smuldering intensity?
That's the stupid face you make.
Ha?
What's going on?
You're having a heart attack.
Breathe! Breathe!
His wohle left side has shut down.